welcome to the show everybody thanks for
being here thanks for listening we're
gonna talk about several things today
including student loan forgiveness we'll
get into that just a moment because
Elizabeth Sanders Elizabeth Bernie
Sanders unveiled her student loan debt
relief plan and it is it's something to
behold so we'll get into that in just
one second but first let's talk briefly
about stamps.com
because nobody really has time no one
has time in general anymore you know
it's it's time is is the one thing we're
all lacking you don't have time to go to
post the post office because you're busy
you got all the traffic in the parking
and lugging all your mail and packages
it can be a hassle that's why you need
stamps calm anything that can save your
time is is worth it these days it's one
of the most popular time-saving tools
for small businesses stamps.com
eliminates trips to the post office and
it saves you money and a dis and gives
you discounts that you couldn't find at
the post office
Stan's comm brings all the amazing
services of the US Post Office right to
your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices or you're an
online seller shipping out products or
you're a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day whatever the case is
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it to
once your mail is ready you just hand it
to your mail carrier or you drop it in
the mailbox and it doesn't get any
simpler than that with stamps.com you
get five cents off every first class
stamp and up to 40% off Priority Mail
not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of these expensive postage meters
that you can get so stamps comm is a no
brainer saving you time and money and
that's why 700,000 small businesses are
already using it so right now here's the
important part my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Walsh
that's stamps.com enter Walsh and you
get all those amazing deals all right
Elizabeth Warren is drowning
in the polls not a lot of excitement
around her campaign even even after
Chevy she's tried a lot of things she
now she's she's live blogging The Game
of Thrones and that didn't work so not
working out now she's going with the
tried and true Democratic strategy of
well if I can't convince you to vote for
me through conventional means then I
will just buy your vote and that's what
she's doing now if she can't get young
folks to vote for her by drinking brews
on Instagram videos or by watching HBO
then she'll bribe them instead and so
that's where Elizabeth Warren's plan for
student debt relief which she announced
yesterday has comes from now I want to
talk a little bit about her plan
specifically and then I want to discuss
why the whole idea of student loan
forgiveness in general or student loan
relief we're calling it now is terrible
we'll do that but let's start with her
plan reading now from an article on CNN
it says Warren's proposal of forgiving
outstanding student debt goes a
significant step further than previous
democratic policy plans
Warren's plan would offer debt relief
based on income households that make
less than a hundred thousand a year
would get fifty thousand dollars in loan
cancellation with the amount of relief
getting gradually smaller as income
level goes up with households that make
more than $250,000 not eligible for any
debt relief at all altogether would
white it would wipe out all student debt
including both federal and private loans
for more than 75 percent of Americans
without standing loans the universal
free college portion of Warren's plan
makes public college free for everyone
regardless of their finances while
Sanders Bernie Sanders's 2015 proposal
offered free tuition for everyone a 2017
bill bat scaled back eligibility based
on income blah blah blah okay so by this
plan you could be by this plan you could
be getting you can be making twenty
grand a to hunt to you could be making
$200,000 a year in income as an engineer
or a doctor or some
and you could still get your loans at
least significantly discounted now
here's the question of course how are we
going to pay for this new bundle of
goodies go back to CNN for that it says
the campaign estimates that the plan
would cost 1.25 trillion dollars over
ten years the revenue from Warren's
wealth tax proposal a two percent tax on
wealth above 50 million and a three
percent tax on wealth above a billion
would pay for her newest proposal
according to her campaign so okay so she
claims we can pay for this whole thing
by taking money from the evil wealthy
folks and redistributing it now there is
of course no reason at all to believe
that this responsibility would
ultimately land just on the wealthy
these kinds of proposals never remain as
limited in practice as they were on
paper and this proposal is not even that
limited on paper in the first place
not to mention you have all the familiar
problems of further encouraging job
creators to leave the country especially
now that you're advertising that you're
going to force them to pick up the tab
for all of the student debt in the
country and and you have the problem
that these these kinds of taxes tend to
trickle down as as the cost gets passed
on to the working class so that's just
the beginning of our problems right
there are many other problems and I want
to go through them one by one or as many
as I can named in a few minutes
number one from a financial perspective
you are talking about doing something
that will make inflation massively worse
which feeds the problem that you're
supposedly trying to solve
so let me here's a few lines from an
editorial this morning on the National
Review which talks about the inflation
aspects of the aspect of this the says
the inflation of college costs is a
genuine concern and one that is of
especially intense interest to the
federal government which thanks to the
Obama administration made itself into a
monopolist in the student loan business
but senator Warren here proposes to put
out a fire with gasoline ie to mitigate
the effects of inflation by dumping
money on the problem in
inflation-adjusted terms government
spending on higher education has never
been higher
it has climbed by nearly $2,000 per
student since 2001 as yet is the
foundation for economic education points
out Pell grants spending alone rose 72
percent in the few short years from 2008
to 2013 tuition and other expenses have
risen right along with the spending then
you know goes on from there so if you
want to get control over tuition
inflation as as this as the point the
National Review is making is you got to
turn off the you got to turn off the
spigot you can't you can't you're making
the problem worse by just dumping money
on to a problem that has a lot to do
with inflation so that's the financial
part of it second there are a lot of
people a lot of working class people who
chose not to go to college who accepted
a life of lower income because they
couldn't afford it you know and they
knew they couldn't afford it and they
didn't want to take on the debt and that
that that seemed like a prudent and wise
decision that a lot of people in the
working class made I can't afford it I'm
not gonna buy it so what you're now
saying to them is that they're prudent
and wise decision to not buy something
they couldn't afford was actually
foolish they are suckers yet again
because they should have just went ahead
and bought it because they they wouldn't
have to pay for it anyway they could
have gone and not paid is what you're
telling them they made that sacrifice
for nothing student loan forgiveness is
a plan that helps the upper class and
screws the middle and lower classes
where most non college grads reside so
just think about it this is a plan to
bail out people who are you know
sometimes making 150 180 thousand
dollars a year while those making 60 or
50 or $40,000 a year
are still going to be stuck with all of
their debts house car credit card
whatever so it's completely absurd this
is basically
this is you know student loan
forgiveness is essentially welfare for
the upper-class because that's where
most college grads are they're gonna be
the middle you know upper-middle class
to upper class whereas the millions of
people who did go to college oftentimes
are lower middle to lower class and so
this is a plan that helps those people
on the upper echelon while doing nothing
for the people who are below them third
problem what about all the people who
went to college and paid their debts
okay what about the person who has just
paid the last dime on their $100,000
debt and made all those sacrifices along
the way and had to work very hard to pay
it off and they did it and now they're
gonna turn around and see that everyone
else's debt is just wiped clean anyway
it is that not an injustice is that not
grossly unfair are you gonna refund them
I mean how can you possibly say oh think
about the sacrifices that these and
their many people are going to be in
this situation who are just on the verge
of paying off their loans think about
all the sacrifices they had to make
think about how their life has been
affected by this and now you're going to
just wipe everyone else's clean after
they do they get a refund is the
question how is it you know equality
under the law is supposed to be
guaranteed how is it equality under the
law to give this massive unearned bonus
to a certain segment of population while
everyone else is out of luck
fourth problem even putting aside the
financially disastrous effects of a plan
like this and putting aside how it
screws the working class and it screws
people who are responsible for their
deaths in the first place we're still
left with a very simple fact nobody
forces anyone to take on these loans
that's a choice that you make if you
have student debt you have it because
you agreed to it you signed on the
dotted line now you guys I was 19 I
didn't know okay but you still made that
choice
you made a legal agreement everything
else aside it is in
moral for a third party such as the
government or Elizabeth Warren to come
in and say oh never mind you don't have
to fulfill your obligations and keep
your promises just just the very idea
that Elizabeth Warren or Bernie Sanders
or any of these Democrats the very idea
that they would say yeah we're gonna I'm
gonna forgive that look it's not for you
to forgive what I mean you're gonna
forgive it
you didn't grant the loan it's not up to
you to forgive it and it's certainly not
up to some other private citizen to to
have to come in and pay off the loan out
of forgiveness if you took the loan out
this is your responsibility and so
that's really see that that's what you'd
have to explain and this is my challenge
okay to any college grads who are
arguing for loan forgiveness this is my
challenge to you or if you're listening
right now this is what I want you to do
present a morally and logically sound
argument explaining why some other
citizen should be forced by the state to
pay your debt that you assumed by choice
for a product that you bought and will
keep that's what you have to explain it
and in maybe phrase it in exactly these
terms I believe someone else should be
forced to pay my loans because and then
fill in the blank i I don't I don't I'm
not sure that you can fill in the blank
with I think and and the point is you
know we talked about student loan relief
and forgiveness and we talked about it
in these sorts of abstract ambiguous
terms know what we're talking about and
if you are advocating for student loan
forgiveness what you are saying is that
someone else some other citizen should
have to pay your loans that's what
you're saying
and so you should at least phrase it
that way and make your argument here's
another way of looking at it you're in
debt okay and it sucks
I know it's not fun maybe it's
even unfair who knows I don't know you
did agree to it but but whatever the
point is you're in debt the debt has to
be paid okay
someone has to pay him the debt you
agreed to while purchasing the product
you want and we'll keep that has to be
paid so it's it can't just be erased the
only question is who should pay it you
or someone else should it should it be
the person who took on the debt who pays
it or the person who did not take on the
debt and so what you have to do is come
up with an argument to explain why yeah
this debt has to be paid but it
shouldn't be by me it should be by that
guy over there fifth thing whatever
possible argument could be made whatever
you might be able to put in the blanks
there to say well someone else should
pay my loans because it would clearly
apply just as much to any other form of
debt mortgage car credit card so if
you're struggling with student loan debt
and it's making your life difficult it
but I didn't go to college and but I'm
struggling to pay my mortgage where
where where's my get-out-of-jail-free
card why are you special why do you get
to get this and why I mean what about
the rest of us who are stuck with debt
and don't say oh well you can file for
brank bankruptcy okay bankruptcy ain't
free that's not the same thing you don't
have to under these plans you're not
gonna have to file for bankruptcy you
just get you just kidding you could you
just get to walk away from it like it
never happened
well what about me why don't I get that
and see what I would I make this
argument say well what about me I want
something too right
you can't say all that selfish that's up
well yeah you're the one big selfish I
mean if this is the way it's gonna go
now where are you where the government
just you know you've you're you're in a
tough spot so the government comes in
with someone else's money and bails you
out then what then it's perfect it is
perfectly valid for me to say you know
what I want it too okay I got this debt
I got that debt I'm struggling with this
I want all that taken care of maybe you
should have to pay for it you know if
someone else has to pay your loans and
maybe you should have to pay mine you
know what I want you to pay my
that's what you should have to do
because I don't want to pay it it's hard
for me I could I could I could I could
pull out the violin and I could sing you
a whole song a whole sad song about how
difficult it is to pay my mortgage and
so you should have to pay that's what I
think yeah I shouldn't have to you
should have to well I mean it was
predatory I mean they never should have
sold me this house in the first place
they should have known I can't afford it
right sixth thing here this whole
problem can be solved a long term with a
very simple societal change
we don't need loan forgiveness or free
college or anything else there's a very
simple change that could be made if
people would just wait a couple of years
before going to college okay that that's
oh that's really I think that could
almost solve all these problems this
idea and I you know I just I go on about
this all the time because it's so
obvious to me that number one as I've
said many times you know not everyone
has to go to college and and and there
are way more people going to college
than should be and what that doesn't
mean that everyone should go like if if
you are going to get into a line of work
where a four-year degree is actually
necessary and those kinds of jobs do
exist obviously if you want to be a
doctor lawyer engineer architect you
know I could go on and on those kinds of
jobs exist and so if you're going to get
a job like that if that's the plan then
yep going and getting a four-year degree
makes sense and you should do that
and the good news there there is that a
lot of those are high-paying jobs so
you'll be able to pay off the debt but
if you don't know what you want to do
with your life if you have no idea what
your skills are what your interests are
what your you know abilities are what
your plan is five years down the road I
mean if you have no clue and that is the
the situation that most high school
graduates are in at the age of
eighteen years old then of course you
shouldn't go right to college there's no
reason to there is no good argument at
all that anyone can make to explain why
an eighteen year old kid who doesn't
know what he wants to do with his life
should go right to college what what
would be explain this to me what would
be the downside of an eighteen year old
kid who doesn't know what he wants to do
going and getting a job somewhere for a
few years first you can still go when
you're 20 it's not a race it'll be fine
that we're it's not a competition I mean
there is a competition for jobs out
there but it's not it's not a it's not
like we you have to get to the finish
line
before the other person so the point is
if there was a simple societal change
that is perfectly feasible that what the
message we send the kids is if you know
exactly what you want to do with your
life and you know you need the four-year
degree then maybe you could think about
going there right after high school but
even in that case I mean even if you
want to be a doctor I don't see any
downside to going and getting a job for
a few saving up some money getting some
experience and then going but at least
in that case I could see the argument
maybe for going right there but
everybody else just go get a job okay it
doesn't matter what you're doing like go
even if you're willing work in
McDonald's or you're working at Walmart
or you know you're moving across the
country for you three years getting a
job someone whatever you do just do
something get a job in the meantime
you're making money you're saving you're
putting yourself in a in a in a better
position to afford college and most
importantly you're figuring yourself out
you're figuring out what you actually
are good at and what you want to do
because there is a huge difference
between an eighteen-year-old kid who's
never had a job and is just getting out
of high school and a 20 or 21 year old
adult who's been in the workforce for a
few years there's a huge difference in
maturity in in in in self understanding
in in so many areas so I don't I mean
until someone can explain what's wrong
what I'm saying here until someone could
explain why we need every
eighteen-year-old to just go right to
college without any interment between
until someone can explain that to me
that I'm gonna say that my solution is
the solution and that's what we should
do and if you do that then I think a lot
of these problems start to go away
they're ultimately you're gonna have
fewer people going to college because
there's a there are a lot of people who
if they take that interim period they're
going to discover in the meantime that
oh you know what I don't really need to
go to college I figured out that I want
to be a mechanic or I want to I want to
get it be electrician or you know
something like that so there gonna be a
lot of people don't end up going and the
people who do go are going to be a
little bit more mature and and wise
about it and I think colleges are going
to have to compete a little more for to
get students in in the doors because
it's not going to be an automatic kind
of conveyor belt system where the kids
go right from high school to college and
that's gonna drive costs down I just
think this is the solution and we saw we
don't need to do any of this other stuff
all right
Bernie Sanders wants the Boston Marathon
bomber and convicted rapists and other
assorted ne'er-do-wells in jail to vote
watch this
you have said that you if the people
with felony records should be allowed to
vote while in prison does this mean that
you would support enfranchising people
like the Boston Marathon bomber a
convicted terrorist and murderer do you
think that those convicted of sexual
assault should have the opportunity to
vote for politicians who could have a
direct impact on women's rights okay
thank you for the question and and let
me just say this what our campaign is
about and what I believe is creating a
vibrant democracy today as you may know
we have one of the lowest voter turnouts
of any major country on Earth I want to
see us have one of the highest voter
turnouts and by the way what we are
seeing is more young people getting
involved in the political process but
not enough and in my view
if young people voted at the same
percentage that older people voted in
this country we would transform this
nation but to get to your point we live
in a moment where cowardly Republican
governors are trying to suppress the
vote and in fact right here as you may
know in New Hampshire the legislature
and the governor are working hard to
make it more difficult for young people
to vote and to me that is an incredibly
undemocratic unamerican process and I
say to those people by the way if you
don't have the guts to participate in
free and fair elections you should get
another job and get out of politics all
right so we got up so here is and to
answer your question as it happens in my
own state of Vermont from the very first
days of our state's history but our
Constitution says is that everybody can
vote that is true some people in jail
can vote now here is my view if somebody
commits a serious crime sexual assault
murder they're going to be punished they
may be
jail for 10 years 20 years 50 years 2
whole lives that's what happens when you
commit a serious crime but I think the
right to vote is inherent to our
democracy yes even for terrible people
because once you start chipping away and
you say well like I committed a terrible
crime not gonna let him vote or that
person did that not gonna let that
person vote you're running down a
slippery slope so I believe that people
who commit crimes they pay the price
when they got out of jail I believe they
certainly should have the right to vote
but I do believe that even if they are
in jail they are paying their price to
society but that should not take away
their inherent American right to
participate in our democracy ok a few
things here first of all Democrats are
super excited about voter turnout among
certain demographics right you don't see
them down in the trailer parks in
Alabama trying to try to rustle up some
votes and I'm willing to bet the trailer
parks probably have a low voter turnout
also but you don't see that they're not
down they're not trying to get those
folks out why is that well because those
people are less likely to vote Democrat
so that's what this is about Sanders
pretends to care about participation in
our democracy but he only wants certain
people to participate so he's no better
than the quote cowardly Republican
governors that he's railing against
second I'm doing everything in list
format today if you had noticed
participating in our democracy by voting
is not an inherent right it is not a
god-given right it is not something that
we necessarily want everyone to do it is
not something that our country benefits
from our country does not automatically
become more vibrant just because
everyone is voting voting should be seen
as much more of a responsibility than a
right and in fact in general I think
that we should be if we're it we should
be using the the R word responsibility
more often than we use the R word rights
we should be talking about our
responsibilities
more than our rights and every right is
is a company by a responsibility and I
think we should start looking at it more
in those terms so when you frame it that
way and instead of saying oh we all have
it we all have a right to vote no we all
voting is a responsibility and if it's a
responsibility that means that you
should only do it if you are a
contributing informed knowledgeable
member of society those are the people
who we want voting and that is how our
democracy and our country becomes more
vibrant when you have contributing
informed knowledgeable members of
society voting but when you've got just
a bunch of ignorant when you've got a
bunch of ignorant is who you manage to
to shuffle into the to herd into the
polls on Election Day like cattle and
they just go in there and start pressing
buttons randomly or you know based on
the letter next to the name or based on
whose name is prettier or based on
whatever poster they happen to see when
they were stumbling and half-drunk into
the polls that morning that does not
make our democracy more vibrant that
doesn't that doesn't help our system at
all all you're doing in that case is you
are you are cancelling out the informed
votes with all with all of these
ignorant people and that doesn't help us
so really what we want in this country
are fewer voters not more there should
be fewer whatever the voter turnout is
it should be like half of that or tenth
of that and and that's how that is how
we make a more powerful and vibrant
democracy but the whole idea is as far
as prisoners go the whole idea is absurd
because they're in prison okay we we
already take away their fundamental
right to like walk outside and look at
the clouds right I mean all of their
rights really or most of them are
suspended in prison your First Amendment
right is curtailed severely you can't
say whatever you want your second
Amendment right obviously is gone you're
not carrying guns fourth amendment is
basically gone
prisoners have some basic rights very
basic but by necessity and also for
punitive reasons many of their essential
rights are either gone or severely
limited and we already know that that's
that's the nature of prison so voting is
just one of them it's not even the most
important one so this idea that there is
there's some extra injustice and not
allowing them to vote I mean we keep
them locked in a cage right for 20 hours
a day like what do you I mean then
you're worried that they're not voting
it seems to me that if we're saying oh
well they they have an inherent right to
vote well then I guess they have an
inherent right not to be locked in the
cage in the first place - well then of
course at that point now we have no more
prisoner prisons and we have anarchy so
it doesn't make any sense and the last
thing is I agree actually with with
those who say that felons who get out of
prison should be able to vote now I do
think it's an injustice that someone
who's paid their debt to society and you
know has gone through the punishment and
has reformed themselves the idea that
they can never vote again like if you if
you commit a you know let's say you're
someone Rob's a liquor store when
they're 19 years old and they go to
prison they do their time they get out
they get a job they start a family and
now they're 50 years old it's it's been
over 30 years since they committed the
crime they have long since paid their
debt to society and at the age of 50
they still can't vote that doesn't make
any sense to me
and so yeah I think those people should
be able to vote and in fact those people
could be very valuable voters I mean
these are people who've they've been in
the system they've seen the government
from sort of a different angle than a
lot of us have they've got an experience
they've had they have a sort of life
experience that I think makes their
perspective interesting and valuable and
so yeah I think those people should but
the
those who are in prison are still paying
they are they're still in the process of
paying their debt to society and what's
more and this is the important fact they
are not contributing members of society
okay these are people who have because
of their own actions we have had to
segregate them from society and keep
them locked away and take care of them
you know pay for them to pay to house
them and feed them and everything else
pay for medical care everything else so
these are in prison I mean these people
are are strains on society they're not
contributing and that should be that
that is the that should be the litmus
test is it should be contributing
members of society and that's that is
how our system was originally set up now
obviously back in the you know the early
part of our country's existence when
well you could only vote if you were a
landowner well the problem there is that
you couldn't be a landowner if you are a
woman or if you were a black person so
obviously that was unjust because your
disenfranchising people then based on
gender and race clearly we can't do that
but these days that's not the case
anymore no it doesn't matter your gender
your race you can be legally and in
every other sense a contributing member
of society and so that's how I think we
should decide who can vote let's go to
able do emails now Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
says this is from Kerry says Matt
seriously what's up with the B thing I
don't understand it so Kerry is
referring I guess to my flurry of post
this weekend talking about the arrival
of my bees who I'm going to pick up an
order of bees today actually I'm
starting a bee hive I'm becoming a
beekeeper as I mentioned before and so I
was I was you know I was right I got
tweeted about it this weekend just you
know out of excitement to begin my
journey as a beekeeper the funny thing
is that my wife you know she agreed to
this arrangement
I mean she's known for like two years
that I wanted to start being a beekeeper
and so now it's finally happening then I
was talking her this weekend say oh you
know I'm going to pick up the
this week and and she said oh so it's so
you know how many bees are gonna be it's
gonna be like two hundred two hundred
three hundred bees right and I said no
the original package will be about ten
thousand bees and then it will grow to
seventy or eighty thousand bees and then
I'll probably get more hives and she was
not pleased to learn that fact but I
mean it's too late now it's happening
we're gonna have 70 thousand bees in our
backyard with our kids running around
and pledge it just it is happening and
then she said to me she said she said
well but my mom is allergic to bees and
now she's not gonna be able to come over
and I said oh yeah I hadn't thought of
that I mean that's not like that was the
whole point here now why do I want to be
a beekeeper well because for one thing
why not carry I mean why not be a
beekeeper okay give me one good reason
to not be a beekeeper and then maybe I
won't be and and also I think that it's
well secondly I think bees are
fascinating creatures and third I think
that that IIIi I believe that it's
important for a man to have hobbies and
if that hobby is one that scares your
mother-in-law away well that's just a
win-win folks that's all that is all
right this is from Stephen says hey Matt
I've been a reader even before you start
at the blaze so I'm happy to see your
success so far and hope God continues to
bless you as you continue to share your
viewpoint regarding speaking in tongues
I am a hundred percent on board with you
I've been in multiple churches we're
speaking in tongues was widely accepted
in most churches where this is accepted
speaking in tongues is equated with
praying in the spirit
despite absolutely ignoring Paul's
admonition that if someone speaks in
tongues there should be an interpreter
I've seen multiple people spew out
nonsense gibberish on a regular basis in
my opinion it's a show purely for
self-aggrandizement aggrandizement to
put themselves on pedestal as being the
holiest of the congregation every time
that that tongues are mentioned in the
New Testament it is of the effect of
preaching the word to someone that does
not know of Jesus not just a bizarre
prayer language Paul also said in
Philippians do nothing from selfish
ambition or conceit but in humility
count others more significant than
yourselves
this idea of speaking in tongues as I've
seen it in more
churches does nothing more than elevate
certain people as being more holy than
others so in every sense the way that
speaking in tongues is practiced in the
vast majority of churches directly
contradicts what the Bible tells us I
believe that God can cause us to speak
in tongues to spread his word but the
way I see it in our modern churches
isn't is it is nothing short of
blasphemy sorry to write such a long
screen but having seen this in practice
in so many places I feel very strongly
about it and I will let that stand on
its own because I you put it very well
so thank you for that Steven this is
from redacted great Xia Craddock
dictator met I am a recent Seminary grad
with quite a bit of debt to pay off you
said you don't want to hear a recent
grad with debt to advocate for it
because they are biased so I will offer
the complete opposite
I find this student loan forgiveness by
warrant to be absurd though I stand to
gain a lot financially from it it is
complete exploitation of those that gave
me alone and it is immoral to expect the
American people's tax dollars to pay for
something I contractually agreed to pay
long story short I do not want my
student loans forgiven I have my pride
in my dignity I that is a wonderful
attitude
I agree me that your attitude is so rare
right I mean but that is that's an
American attitude right that's that's
that's how Americans should be that I
don't want you to I I would I would turn
it down if you offered it I don't want
you to just take care of my
responsibilities for me they are mine
and it means something like dignity and
just being a self-sufficient person and
and Manning up and you know taking care
of your of your own business I mean that
means something I want to do that I
don't want you to take that away from me
I don't want you to do it by taking from
someone else I don't want some
millionaire to be my sugar daddy and
come in and
and do that I'm a man you know I've got
dignity that appears to be your attitude
and I think it's I think it's great I
just wish that you weren't such a rarity
I mean I wish that you weren't one out
of a hundred I wish that you were you
know 90 out of a hundred had that
attitude and I think there was a time in
this country when most people had a
similar attitude to yours but these days
people they just they they have no they
certainly have no dignity they have no
desire to be self-sufficient they just
are looking for the easiest way and so
for them there's there's a total
disconnect because it's like they can't
even they can't offer any arguments they
don't even understand why they need to
offer arguments because for them they
say well what do you mean I mean I have
these loans it's hard to pay them off I
don't like them so someone else should
pay them of course they should and if
you ask it well why should they pay well
because it's it's because it's hard for
me and I don't want to have to do it and
that's their whole argument it's not
even an argument it's it's it's the
argument of a two-year-old but you hear
this from grown adults all right let's
see from from Sam says hello Matt I
recently joined a church this is a first
and a big first for me before this I was
religious but not in a good way so I'll
just leave that there I have no
education on church or the teaching and
have never read the Bible honestly so do
bear with me if it if anything I say
sounds wrong since it probably is and
I'm new as new can be but learning my
fiancee got me to go and join them 21 I
never thought I would do this so I've
been going for something like six weeks
now I'm enjoying it and the lead pastor
I feel is good my issue was thinking
about everything I'm being told here
they talk a lot about feeling the Holy
Spirit and hearing Jesus and the Word of
God in one's life does feeling this or
the ability to recognize what God /
Jesus / the Holy Spirit is trying to
tell me or lead me to get easier or more
obvious I feel like I'm being told about
a brand new color
on the color wheel and people will point
to it and saying that it is the color
but I'm having a hard time seeing this
color also talking about how God has
given me a purpose and a gift to fulfill
that purpose how do you know the purpose
given and how do I know the gift /
talent given to fulfill that promise if
I find the purpose I will chase it and
build it I remember something about
three people going to Jesus with gifts
to showing that they had taken the gifts
and created more gifts and the last one
didn't and he was slothful and wicked so
how do I figure all this out any help
with any of this is greatly appreciated
well great question Sam and
congratulations on making a positive
change in your life it takes guts to
make changes I mean it takes guts to
make changes to realize that changes
need to be made and to end humility to
realize that okay this is a this is
something that I don't have in my life I
want to have it and so I'm going to take
that step so that's that's awesome we've
got two emails in a row here from people
with with an attitude that I wish
everyone had in our country would be so
much better if everyone if everyone was
like Sam and in the last email or we'd
be at a much better country now asked
you a question
it is an excellent question and an
important one I think it brings up an
interesting point you talk about feeling
the Holy Spirit and hearing God in your
life and you're basically saying okay
well when does that happen because I'm
going to church I don't really feel it I
don't hear it you the comparison you
made about a new color on the color
wheel is very apt and insightful so I I
think this is part of the problem with
the kinds of the kind of like
charismatic movement in the church in
America in modern times and I don't know
if this is a charismatic church you're
going through but there is a charismatic
vein that you can find in almost any
church in America where there is this
incredible emphasis that is put on
feeling so much so that you begin to
think that religion really is supposed
to be like a drug like opium like Karl
Marx famously said that religion is the
opiate of the masses and and you start
to feel defective if you don't have that
feeling if you don't get that high that
rush if your experience is more dry more
sometimes lonely
sometimes confused even even desolate at
times and what I would say is don't
worry about that don't worry about the
feelings because they'll come they'll go
they'll come back again it's not about
that feelings are notoriously difficult
to conjure up and once you do they're
notoriously difficult to retain and hold
on to and you can't it slips out of your
hands like like like water right and the
people who claim to always be moved by
the spirit it's always be overcome with
these feelings of joy and peace and so
on maybe some of them are I mean maybe
some of them really that that's how it
is
but there are also people who are moved
I think they think that they're moved by
the spirit or by God but but often I
think they're moved by the experience or
by the music or just by the print a sort
of power of suggestion from the people
around them it's not necessarily the
Holy Spirit all the time it could be you
know but but it's not always and there
are people who are just more susceptible
to getting caught up in the moment in an
environment in a crowd where everyone is
sort of feeling a certain way and there
are people who are more likely to to
kind of share that feeling because
they're in the crowd and it's it's not
necessarily because they're more
spiritually in tune than you are it's
just they're a different kind of person
and especially if you're a more kind of
independently minded person a little bit
less susceptible to suggestion and all
of that then you're not going to be as
caught up and and that's okay I was
talking to someone recently who told me
that they are overcome with a feeling of
peace and comfort every time they go to
church and I said every time really
every time you go to church your whole
life you you're overcome with peace and
comfort and they said yeah every single
time in and now I very rarely feel that
what I go to church I'll be honest
sometimes on rare occasion but most of
the time I am NOT overcome by peace and
comfort and I'm not saying that this
person is lying I believe that they
really are and I think that's great
that's a grace that was given to them
it's
for them wonderful for me though it's a
struggle and I think for most people it
is and that's also okay I'm and it's
it's not because I'm spiritually
defective or or you are we're just
different sorts of people
I think the point here is that there is
too much emphasis put on the emotional
experience and faith is portrayed too
much as a sort of joyride a source of
constant comfort or whatever and so it
ends up with this kind of gloss to it
this air of unreality when the reality
is for many Christians that faith is
going to often be a struggle and it's
going to sometimes be painful and it's
going to sometimes be dry and difficult
and a lot of other things and the church
doesn't want to deal with that much of
the time we don't want to confront it we
don't want to talk about it we don't
want to look at it or acknowledge it and
that makes it all the harder for those
of us who are not blessed with that
charismatic gene so I just that's
something to know going in and once you
know it put it to the side don't worry
about it and if you're at church it's
good that you're there you're doing what
you should be doing what I would
recommend is don't stand there sit there
trying to get yourself to feel a certain
way don't worry about that just be there
listen to the to the word that's being
spoken and and that will come and go and
and don't don't focus on too much as for
figuring out your purpose well the good
news is you're 21 you've got plenty of
time to do that the fact that you're
thinking about it and that you're
searching is a great start it's it
already sets you apart from a lot of
people who are in your position at your
age who aren't even thinking about it or
worrying about what they're going to do
or what their ultimate purpose is so the
fact that you want to know and are
searching is good and I would say so
that would be my answers right now it
seems to me knowing almost nothing about
you it seems to me that you're right now
your purpose is to seek and to search
and so that's what you're doing and do
that and I think over time the picture
will get clearer for you
alright thanks for that text that email
we will leave it there thanks for
listening everybody thanks for watching
god speed I'm Michael Knowles host of
the Michael Noel's show Democrats kick
off a major 2020 Town Hall by endorsing
voting rights for terrorists and rapists
we examine the novel electoral strategy
check it out at Daily wire calm